shopping malls and stores closed across
the country city streets empty as
millions remain confined to their homes
factories shot or reopening at a snail's
pace none of this is good news for Apple
the world's most valuable tech company
makes iPhones at various sites across
China and also sells millions of them at
stores around the country the profit
warning underlines just how serious the
corona virus outbreak is for a business
like Apple which is heavily reliant on
its supply chains in China as well as
its strong customer base there Apple had
already been facing challenges in China
before the outbreak in 2019 the company
made sales of forty four billion dollars
in the country a fall of 12 percent from
2018 and the relative value of the
Chinese market for Apple has been
declining in recent years in 2015
the country accounted for 25 percent of
Apple's total revenue that has fallen
steadily last year's figure accounted
for just 17 percent if it is not
contained the corona virus outbreak
could dramatically increase Apple's
difficulties the company has already
said that worldwide iPhone supply will
be temporarily constrained due to the
outbreak for more on this let's bring in
Conrad boozin our financial
correspondent in Frankfurt Conrad and
all this coming at a time when the share
price of Apple is trading not far from a
record high how big a risk
is this for investors how vulnerable are
financial markets right now well
Christoph you're right on the very high
level that share markets are trading on
right now of course there are sort of
vulnerable to setbacks and to profit
taking but I can tell you Christophe
generally speaking
investors are still also pretty
confident confident that the negative
impact the negative economic impact of
all this will eventually be limited and
short-lived and confidence that the
government's are doing whatever they can
to keep business going or help business
to get going again and what you just
also reported you know this announcement
by the government in Beijing to lift
tariffs on medical products from the
United States that certainly is an
indicator for this well Apple is
certainly not the only company that a
company that's seeing its supply chains
disrupted here which companies from
Germany are most in trouble well
certainly the car makers and the
suppliers for the car sector they are
the most they are the ones with the most
integrated supply chains in between
themselves and also over country borders
so BMW Daimler Volkswagen they all are
seeing their production lines in China
stopped right now also suppliers like
Schaeffler continental Robusto and other
European car makers like Fiat already
have talked about that soon they might
be forced to close European factories
because the parts from China are not
company conrad busan and frankfurt thank
you